I love it inside good defense by Dallas
quickly out of the line
four batches now is when you're taking a
nap so looks like the Dallas Mavericks
have the wood working from their hands
it came hard away
and how James comes back with a layup
Jim lately they've been scoring a
hundred and forty points a game the last
Tuesday's preceding this bad wall number
two and one
they don't Doublemint least he's got two
or three defendants wait notches and to
stay on Dodgson dodged it steps back
Vijay gets in his landing spaceman
budgets the hug sit down on the glass
fella got the rebound pass capela
that's how propellers gotta play in this
game this he's got his wrong porzingis
good athlete and Kimbrough but he has to
sprint didn't single times out before is
gonna wear out quickly notches hips he
easily could be one of the top five
teams in the league at the end of the
season capela back outside and Russell
hits the three TV it's incredible how
tall he is how long his arms are and
what a big advantage that is I put the
Rockets have to do Matt was able to get
a hand on the ball on the way up harden
passes out of the double-team PJ
wide-open art to the middle puts it up
and got it
along right out of Utah step back by
Harden
James learn now with 12 points in the
first quarter for sadhus who won the MVP
last season when harden averaged 36 and
dodge is the favorite player flavor this
year house - PJ down to capela no ahead
courier on it but didn't seem and harden
all the way to the basket Rockets and
they break it down into the paint and
then they kick it back out to hardens
playing one-on-one with no help so as
James is continuing to have to face
double-team zip that good rim protector
doesn't have to block every shot just
has to make it more tip Rockets bench
has not been a high scoring bench all
season long they've got to get that
harden takes it right to the basket
one extra second to whatever might win
the game later on down the line here's
Harden in the open court all the way to
the basket for to Jackson just had no
chance gotcha and harden notches with a
step
to how he was really able to stay under
control and he drives fellas got a size
advantage and puts it on the floor
for the mattress I just walked him right
in that's how strong he is
the nifty move that notches tries a lot
only 20 years old he's got the smooth
veterans don't know about there's
hardware the layout
Gracie's College got it right this don't
even jump it in
there's James with a steel in the open
court
the basket scoops it up and in the three
points for heart
shoot it and hit it
when they're both big to harden at six
fives najin's six seven Vijay from the
corner
[Music]
now to keep playing defense sausage to
the basket lays it up and a great play
and a foul on rivers hesitating and then
throwing up to this lob man right there
maxi cleaver who Abhi's again sticks out
Hardaway
tonio but he did have a trip with San
Antonio and there's played well here
today with 18 points and 10 rebounds
mouse in the house for dodges they
really like somebody like Magic Johnson
and there's Harden to the basket for two
that's a toughy well partnership
downcourt past the house at the other
end for two
the pastor Martin pull the pecan pie
Martin tolet pass PJ
another assist with Jane out on the
perimeter with dachshunds who walks his
way down for two an law
this is witched off obnoxious now
there's no help defender in there to
protect the rim you see Austin coming
over good hustle house is able to keep
the ball alive Westbrook to the basket
[Applause]
I was there and
colleges because they are deduces
challenge earlier in games easy layup
l'amour goes with 16 Capello in 1929 for
art Westbrook with 25 notches took
porzingis his trip and watch porzingis
cutting it along the baseline he's tall
enough to look at his hip in the park
[Applause]
McLemore back the other way adoption in
accounting and Hardin thousand right
there one two three steps actually he
actually traveled after four minutes
left to play in the game Aachen puts it
up and in and he's fouled on the play
slow down right laughs slow down and
then it gets clobbered in the face by
Westbrook at on the drive back outside
the rivers clot by dodging
[Applause]
and porzingis comes out of there with it
Miami Heat coming in Wednesday and you
know what Miami did to Houston on the
last Cup
start the clock something yeah what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content